well friends
if i know one thing it's that getting
the crap scared out of you is a
universal language so today we're gonna
take a look at the top five best
spanish language horror films right now
on the ketchup
head over to ryantomatos.com for our
full list of the best spanish language
horror movies ranked by tomato meter
it's got everything you're looking for
in horror
zombies vampires creepy kids you get it
and we're gonna break down the top five
from that list starting with number five
the similars this sci-fi horror flick is
about eight people who get trapped in a
remote bus station on a rainy october
night in 1968 where
paranoia and strange phenomenon set in
why is it always gotta rain though
and by using this period piece as a
backdrop critics
praised mexican writer director isak
espon for the way that he paid homage to
some of his horror influences like the
twilight zone and b-movies of the 60s
and 70s
you've just crossed over into the
twilight zone sorry i can never help
myself
[Music]
number four on this list is the animated
horror film the wolf house which is
certified fresh and has an impressive
audience score of 92 percent
inspired by true events creepy this film
tells the story of a young woman
in southern chile who escapes from a
german colony and takes refuge in a
strange house in the woods this
description alone
is terrifying filmed over the course of
five years the critic's consensus for
the wolf house is that it's a
stunning outpouring of creativity whose
striking visuals
queasily complement its disturbing story
and i am for sure adding queasily to my
vocab today
voya transformer a miserable enclave
coming in at number three is 2020's la
yorona
putting a fresh spin on the hispanic
american folklore this film is about a
woman in guatemala who comes back to
haunt the general who ordered the
genocide of her and her family 30 years
earlier
and if that sounds creepy it is but as
roger ebert.com's monica castillo wrote
it's not just a creepy story but a
painful reflection of injustice
clawing its way to the number two spot
on this list is tigers are not afraid
this hit film from writer director isa
lopez has been compared to the work of
oscar-winning director guillermo del
toro
so it's no surprise to know that del
toro is producing lopez's next film
a werewolf western so stoked for that
now tigers are not afraid is described
as a horror fairy tale set against the
backdrop of mexico's drug wars as it
follows a group of orphaned children
with three magical wishes
and critics say it deftly blends that
fantasy with hard-hitting realism and
leaves a lingering impact
mama and finally the number one film on
our list of the best spanish language
horror films is the 1931 spanish version
of dracula sitting at a hundred percent
on the tomato meter
coming at a time before dubbing movies
into spanish was a thing
studios would just make extra versions
of a movie and this one is one of the
more notable ones
it was actually filmed at night on the
same set as the american version but
with an
entirely different cast and crew and
since it is a bit more racy
violent and over the top at least for
its time many fans consider the spanish
version to be the better film
yo estoy de aguero
all right friends it is time for us to
kick it over to you now let us know what
your favorite spanish language horror
film is in the comments section let us
know all your thoughts and feelings
and for more movie and streaming news
head on over to rottentomatoes.com
and be sure to check out the new rotten
tomatoes is wrong a podcast from rotten
tomatoes because fresh orion is just the
beginning of the conversation and new
episodes drop every thursday
and if you don't want to miss out on any
future episodes of this show be sure to
hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as always we can't
thank you enough for watching the
ketchup my name is nas perez enos vemos
and in proximo video adios
[Music]
you